[Musique]
alors pourquoi un entretien avec nos
plus hauts magistrats et avec la cour de
cassation
premièrement pour
examiner avec les conditions dans
lesquelles il pourrait y avoir un
meilleur dialogue entre les juges et la
société un meilleur dialogue entre les
juges et le band politique il ya
aujourd'hui une situation de défiance
qui est intolérable et complet pas
poursuivre il ya aussi la question de la
pénalisation de la vie publique du moins
la vie publique nationale
il ya peut-être aussi le rôle du juge
dans la production delà de la norme les
juges aujourd'hui de nombreux moyens
d'écarter sur tel ou tel point la loi ce
qui bien sûr a une conséquence contrôle
par une parlement
c'est un petit peu une une organisation
nouvelle et plus fluide à trouver entre
les différents pouvoirs
on le juge interprète mais toujours avec
le souci de respecter la volonté qui a
été celle du législateur est aujourd'hui
effectivement on a évoqué un nombre de
cas d'espèce dans lequel les chambres de
la cour sont amenés à s'intéresser aux
travaux parlementaires pour
effectivement essayé de savoir
lorsqu'une disposition peut être obscur
ou imprécises qu'elle était vraiment
l'intention de dessinateur je pense que
aussi bien haute assemblée que la cour a
gagné beaucoup dans ce genre d'exercice
je pense qu'on vit dans une époque
complexe polémique ou
une certaine défiance vous installer
entre le rôle des différentes
institutions et je pense qu il est donc
essentiel de clarifier par des
discussions comme celle qu'on a eues
aujourd'hui le rôle du législateur est
le rôle du juge moi je trouve
extrêmement intéressant ces échanges
parce que ça nous permet de mieux
comprendre la façon dont le parlement
travail et ça permet en fait au
parlement de mieux comprendre la façon
dont nous raisonnons et j'étais
intéressé par le fait que toutes les
chambres de la cour de cassation ont
indiqué qu'elles se réferrait beaucoup
aux travaux des parlementaires
mais en même temps avec cette
relative complexité de sources de normes
différentes qui viennent de la france
mais qui viennent aussi de l'europe et
du monde